did you know anything about did you did
you know anything about jon jones
martian manhunter
uh at all when you first got this
because i don't even know anything
really about him anyway i mean
what did you do to prepare they said you
have an audition for this or did you
just get an offer for it or
no i got it i got an offer to play uh i
was originally just playing hank henshaw
the guy who runs the deo right um
i think jeff jones and andrew kreitzberg
were
watching the pilot being
shot one day and i i think
jeff jones said [ __ ] guy's great you
know he'd make a great martial manhattan
and they looked at each other and went
[ __ ] do it so
they just sort of they didn't tell me
about it it only told me after the pilot
finished
so once i was in england and shooting a
job in morocco called the night manager
and they my man my agent called me and
said
yeah they want to make you an offer on
that supergirl but they want to change
your character
i was like what i said yeah they want to
make you somebody else
and i was like well who's that and i
emailed the bosses and they were saying
well it's very exciting but we're not
going to tell you
until it's all you know look you know
crosses and dotson's eye you know all
you know everything's signed up
and i i flew to la to shoot the pilot
and i think i got there two weeks early
or something and i phoned up and i said
guys you know
i need to know who the [ __ ] i'm playing
you know so can i come and meet
can i come and come in and meet you guys
so i went in to meet andrew
and he just gave me this pile of comics
and said
you're going to be the martial manhunter
and um
you said who i never know
[Laughter]
the hulk fantastic four i didn't read dc
i wasn't a dc i never read anything i
think i was lex luthor i never read one
comic book i didn't know i just said
[ __ ] it i i'm gonna
i get it i know it's over all over the
comments
so so i so but i didn't know the story
so
i went home and read the marshmallow
answer [ __ ] loved it
loved it i just thought he was great
great character so um
yeah it's been it's been fun it's been
slightly you know
you know they they can't quite afford
you know
he's one of the strongest most capable
characters in the dc camera but they
just can't afford to do his powers
so like you know it's like i'm playing
him on a budget
so i i'm like
it's been really it's been like
sometimes i get my butt kicks i'm like
how the [ __ ] is this guy beating me up
you know you know so
[Music]
often times oftentimes i've had to sort
of
you know just create create create a
kind of whole new iteration of the
character because
um it doesn't quite match
you know with this sort of all-powerful
capable character that's in in the comic
books you know um
it's like it's not my show i can't save
the day right so
if super girls she has to save the day
so so um
so a lot of the times i have to sort of
and i i suspect i suspect
in the very first season just before the
finale i'll get taken out
you know i'll get taken out by some
radiation [ __ ] beam from space
that knocks me out that i can't save the
day you know
and it happens every it happened in
everything
before the finale i'd get some sort of
some [ __ ] alien stone placed around
my neck which
disabled me for
what have you not done as a as that
character
that fans are like well he could do this
why isn't he doing that
we can read minds he can um uh
uh he can uh teleport
i mean there's a whole list of them out
there on on on
on online right right he's
he's an extremely capable character but
unfortunately
we just can't afford it so so it's it's
it's been like
it's been like playing them on a bit of
a budget is it weird being in the final
season of a show that
when someone i don't know if anybody's
ever said this is your final season no
one's ever told me that
so you never know but as an actor is it
harder to go in there and
have something to really you know want
to would you just suck it up and
how does that work i was quite i'm i'm
i'm quite
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready to check
out i've got to be honest i'm ready to
i'm ready to move on so it was quite it
was quite a relief
when they said it's the final season i
was i was okay with that
okay i'm kind of i'm okay with going
home
i'm okay with being around my family um
i took the job for a specific reason and
those reasons have been the black box
has been ticked
um you know it's it's got some some some
money in the bank which has been great
cemented my you know
my sort of uh
position as you know as a as an actor in
the america in the american sort of
a world and you got more fans it's got a
shitload of fans now you got a shitload
of fans that love martian
fans um it's been great so you know so
but i'm i'm ready to chat i'm ready to
move on